Prof: As I said in my
last lecture,
and as you have already--I'm
sure--seen,
the Quixote has two
overarching plots.
One is the story of the mad
hidalgo and his squire,
and the story about the writing
of the novel.
The one about the insane Don
Quixote will acquire coherence
after the fight with the
Biscainer,
as Jarvis calls it in your
translation,
because he and his squire will
now be pursued by the Holy
Brotherhood--
I'll explain what the Holy
Brotherhood is--
and by the priest and the
barber.
His neighbors,
the priest and the barber,
want to return Alonso Quijano
to his home in that unnamed
village in La Mancha.
The episode about the lost
manuscript and the search for
the balance of the story,
the manuscript found and its
translation,
follow themes mentioned in the
prologue about the book's
authorship.
You will also have noticed how
Cervantes plays with the
divisions of the chapters;
they seem to be arbitrary,
they seem to be very whimsical.
These are all winks at the
reader, telling him that this is
a very artful,
artificial and fictional work.
Obviously, also many of these
divisions were made after the
manuscript was finished;
scholars have worked on this
and come to that conclusion.
In the context of the business
of finding the manuscript,
and the balance of the story
and all of that,
one could ask,
who is the second most
important character in the
Quixote?
Is it Sancho?
I think that it is the
narrator, the narrator and his
various agents who appear
throughout the novel.
That would be,
to my mind, the second most
important character in the
Quixote.
Now, in this playing with the
manuscript,
and the lost manuscript,
and all of that,
Cervantes is parodying the
romances of chivalry,
where such devices appear:
Oh!
This manuscript of this novel
was found in a vault somewhere,
it was written by some sage,
and so forth,
and Cervantes is parodying
that.
Remember, a parody is a mocking
imitation of the style of a
literary work or works
ridiculing stylistic practices
by exaggerated mimicry.
In that sense,
a parody is both a criticism
and an homage because it is a
copy of something;
it is a distorted copy,
but it is still a copy.
So the business of the
unfinished manuscript and its
translation rekindles questions
and issues that the narrator
opened in the prologue,
that prologue that we discussed
a number of classes ago.
I will talk a little bit today
about why all of these games of
authorship.
But let us sort of recapitulate
how many texts or virtual texts
we have so far.
We have the original text that
was supposedly written in Arabic
by a lying Moorish historian
called Cide Hamete Benengeli.
The second is the text of the
translation that the narrator
pays for.
Then, a further text is the one
that this narrator presumably
corrects and copies and rewrites
and comments upon in the
margins,
as you will see in several
episodes in the future.
But what about the manuscript
up to chapter VIII and that
narrator?
We have no idea how the
narrator came about that
manuscript, so the text of those
first eight chapters it is not
explained where it came from.
Now, this whole collection of
manuscripts do not make a
coherent system;
you can't reduce it to a
coherent system.
Yes, we have the first one,
the second one,
the third one;
it all remains vague and a
mystery,
and besides,
we know that the whole thing is
a joke beginning with the name
Cide Hamete Benengeli or
berenjena.
What's a berenjena?
Student: Eggplant.
Prof: Eggplant.
That is to say,
his last name could be
'eggplant.'
So it is a joke.
Now, why are Cervantes and his
narrator establishing this
distance from their own text?
How does this distancing mesh
with the authorial willfulness
we found in that first sentence,
where the narrator says
"de cuyo nombre quiero
acordarme,"
the name of which I
purposefully omit,
referring to the village in La
Mancha,
where Don Quixote or Alonso
Quijano lives.
It is as if this modern author,
Cervantes,
could not posit his own
existence without radical
reservations,
self doubts,
self doubts about himself as
creator.
I have emphasized that this
kind of ironic distancing has
echoes of Montaigne's self
deprecatory irony,
also echoes of Erasmus's
irony--I have only mentioned
Erasmus in passing,
the great humanist Erasmus of
Rotterdam,
who had many followers in Spain
and who wrote a book that may be
one of the sources of the
Quixote,
called In Praise of
Folly.
It's a very,
very ironic book,
it's not praising folly,
it is doing so in a mocking
way, but it is that sort of
mocking way that you find in
Cervantes.
Now, it is as if Cervantes were
removing the origin of the text,
were leaving it in a sort of
cloud of mystery,
and that this is part both of
the irony and of the joke.
Remember the quote from
Lukács that I read in the
first lecture about this first
modern novel emerging at a time
when the Christian God has
abandoned the world.
You do not have the
centeredness that you had in
the Divine Comedy,
if you have read Dante.
In the Divine Comedy
everything coheres because there
is a cosmological system and
with the attendant symbolism
provided by the Catholic Church,
by Catholic doctrine,
and so the self of Dante,
the pilgrim is very much--even
though he's also like Don
Quixote--
travelling within a coherent
universe,
and, in fact,
in the very middle of the
Divine Comedy the central
verse of the Divine
Comedy alludes to Dante.
So Dante is at the center of
this coherent universe.
This is not the case in the
Quixote, and these authorial
games underscore that.
This is no longer the case.
Remember that this is,
as I've been saying,
a post-Copernican world,
a world in which the earth is
no longer at the center,
therefore, "man,"
"mankind"
is no longer at the center.
So this is what is at stake,
as it were, in all of these
games.
Again, these are very serious
issues,
but Cervantes always presents
them in a light humorous tone,
which is part of the irony
itself, the humor,
the laughing at one self and
the laughing at others.
So this is a very important
element of the Quixote,
and one that it has in common
with a very famous painting by
Diego Velázquez.
Diego Velázquez,
the great Velázquez
about whom most of you must have
heard.
And that painting--oh,
oh, it's not very well
represented;
it's kind of blurry--is Las
Meninas, The Maids of Honor.
Can we improve a little bit on
the quality of that?
Maybe if we turn off the lights?
Well, that will help, too.
It's out of focus?
Is it better now?
It's better,
but it's out of focus.
Can it be improved at all?
Student:  I can see it
clearly here,
so I don't know what to say...
Student:  The lens of
the projector might be out of
focus.
Prof: Oh,
but it is way up there,
so we can't do anything with
it, can we?
So I have brought both my
pointer and, if you will excuse
me, this little flashlight so I
can look at my notes.
I hope it's not distracting to
you.
As I have perhaps mentioned
before, I am a pilot,
and this is my pilot's
flashlight.
You use it in the cockpit at
night to look at charts and
stuff like that,
and I thought that I could
improvise and use it for this.
Now, as you look at the
painting--and I apologize for
the poor technology and I
promise we will bring a better
one the next time or maybe I'll
make a copy that I can
distribute.
First of all,
as you look at it,
think of what I mentioned
before about Alberti's De
Pictura, the treatise on
perspective.
Remember that I talked about
Leon Alberti,
Leon Battista Alberti,
1404-1472, an Italian who wrote
this treatise on perspective.
He was an architect and wrote
on architecture,
and I really encourage you to
read this little treaty,
it's very brief,
but it's very influential
because he laid down the basis
for perspective in painting.
As you can see,
we do have perspective here
because of the relative size of
the figures as they move away
from the front.
So I just want you to take that
into account.
Now, the relevance of Las
Meninas to the
Quixote is essentially
because of this issue of self
reflexivity.
In both works,
the creator has been given a
prominent place within the work
and in both they appear in their
function as creators of the very
work in question.
That is Velázquez.
And he is, obviously,
in the act of painting,
as Cervantes appears within
the Quixote in the act of
writing the novel.
Now, we look at
Velázquez who looks a
little quizzical--
We will speak a little bit more
about his figure–and you
can recall the words of
Cervantes in the prologue,
when he wrote:
"I often took pen in hand
and as often laid it down not
knowing what to say,
and once upon a time,
being in deep suspense with the
paper before me,
the pen behind my ear,
my elbow on the table,
and my cheek on my hand
thinking what I should
say..."
And you can think of
Velázquez poised in a
similar way,
as if thinking of what to paint
next,
and also actually comparing his
models--
I'll speak about who the models
are--
to what he's painting,
but it's the same moment of
doubt that we have in Cervantes.
It is kind of a visual
aporia--Aporia is
a rhetorical figure to express
doubt.
A-P-O-R-I-A--and a visual
aporia in that
Velázquez seems to be
hesitating what the next brush
stroke will be.
Now, Las Meninas seems
to capture a moment,
and not a very significant
moment, and that is significant
in itself.
How do we know that it's not a
very significant moment?
Well, there are certain
gestures, like this little girl
that just put a foot on the dog;
these figures back here,
if we could see them more
clearly you could see they're
engaged in a trivial
conversation.
The princess is being offered,
I think,
a glass of water of something
by this maid,
and this man in the back is
about to leave the room,
so it's an insignificant
moment, it's a moment like those
in the Quixote,
those many moments that are
contingent,
serendipitous,
things just happened,
not in a sequence,
but just caught,
like a snapshot,
and that is what is important
about this moment in which
Velázquez and all of
these other people in the
painting are caught up.
Now, of the painting,
we see only the back of the
painting, and we see the easel,
the paints, the brush.
That is, we see the instruments
to create the painting,
and, in fact,
we are in Velázquez's
studio,
his workshop,
so Velázquez is painting
the inside of the workshop
within which the work of art is
being created,
as we read about the manuscript
being copied,
translated, and so forth,
given the details about the
composition and the creation of
the novel that we are reading.
This studio of Velázquez
would be akin to Don Quixote's
library where he keeps the books
that have turned him mad.
Now, the other important
element, and perhaps the most,
is that the line between
reality and fiction,
between life and art,
has been abolished.
How so?
Well, who is the model of the
painting?
Well, presumably the king and
queen,
who are reflected on the back
on that mirror,
but the models are truly
ourselves as we position
ourselves in front of the
painting.
In fact, the first time I saw
this painting many years ago in
1969 to be exact--
now it's in a large room and
you can barely get to see the
painting there are so many
tourists looking at it and
guides talking about it and so
forth--
but when I saw it in 1969 at El
Prado Museum it was in a room--
the painting is much larger
than what you see here--
it was in a room for itself,
and the dimensions of the room
and the way that the painting
was positioned the moment you
walked in,
you walked into the painting,
you became the model.
It was really uncanny the
sensation that you had,
you really had the sense that
you had walked into the painting
and you had become the painter's
model,
you had become that which he
was in the process of painting.
So here we are,
becoming the model and there is
Velázquez within his own
painting.
He was a genius,
vain, a little lazy,
boastful.
He's wearing the cross--I think
it's of Calatrava--one of the
military orders.
You didn't become a member of
the Calatrava just like that,
so he's a bit boastful,
and there he is.
Now, all of the self-reflexive
moves that we've seen in the
Quixote are the same here.
We see the painting as it were
from behind, we see the
preparation of the painting but
not the painting itself.
My late friend Severo Sarduy
said that Las Meninas was
within Las Meninas but
backwards,
the same way that in the Arabic
manuscript of the Quixote,
presumably the
Quixote is backwards,
because of course you write
Arabic the other way--
It's a little bit too clever,
perhaps,
but you get the idea that the
painting is within the painting,
but you're not seeing the
painting but how the painting
comes about.
We also have the issue of the
multiple perspectives,
none of them complete.
That is, Velázquez can
see us, can see the model,
he can see the rest of his
studio.
The man in the back is the one
with the most complete view,
because he can see the painting
and he can see the model,
if indeed the models are the
king and queen.
So, ironically,
it is that man who is at that
point who has the most complete
view.
I say ironically because I
detect a pun on
Velázquez's part in that
figure because that,
in terms of perspective,
is more or less about the
point de fuite,
in French, the vanishing point,
the punto de fuga in
Spanish,
that is, point at the center
and the depth of the
perspective,
that is, the vanishing point,
and, ironically,
in that punto de fuga is
a man about to leave,
there is, I think,
a pun involved there--
or perhaps I am being just too
clever like my friend Sarduy.
But the idea is that no one has
a complete perspective;
everything, everybody has a
partial, incomplete perspective,
including the artist.
And this is fundamental because
it makes for this ironic
incomplete view.
Remember, the greatest part of
the irony in Cervantes is that
we only have a partial view of
this infinite world,
this post-Copernican,
now Galileo world--
Galileo who wrote around the
same time,
and Galileo discovered the use
of the telescope,
he discovered the infinite
spaces--So our perspective is
always limited.
So in The Meninas
the perspectives are all
limited, partial,
and in that,
too, the painting and the novel
are alike.
Now, Galileo--I think,
I quoted him in an earlier
lecture, if not I'll quote him
again.
He said: "The more we
know,
the less we know,"
because he was discovering more
stars,
more space, and he knew then
that it would be impossible to
get to know all of space.
We're still in that situation
although we have improved our
capacity.
So what is the significance of
all of this?
What I have just said,
I mean the limits of human
knowledge, the limits of self
knowledge, and what else?
We are the models,
we are the models of the
painting,
and Velázquez has given
himself a prominent position in
a painting that should be a
painting of the king and queen,
so he has usurped the place of
the king and queen.
He has given himself a more
prominent position.
He has, as it were,
erased them to put himself.
This is this ambivalent
position of the modern writer,
or author, or painter,
or artist, about his own
creative powers.
But he has put himself in the
painting instead of those who
should be the models,
the king and queen.
Furthermore,
he has opened the space of the
model so that we,
as we see the painting,
actually occupy the position of
the king and queen.
This has all kinds of political
implications,
you see, the king and queen
have been removed,
and we, who are commoners,
can occupy instead that
position,
so in that sense this is a very
revolutionary painting.
This painting is saying:
anybody can be king and queen;
by just stepping in front of my
painting and becoming my model,
you become king and queen for
that moment--
Remember, there was a show
called 'Queen for a Day,' you
become queen for a day or king
for a day,
you understand--So there has
been a displacement of power
here,
in Velázquez's painting,
by omitting the king and queen
or by relegating them to the
back,
to a reflection,
a very kind of blurry
reflection made more blurry by
our poor copy here,
of the king and queen.
So now, historically,
if you will read your Elliott,
you will see that this reflects
a real political situation in
Spain,
meaning that,
in fact, the power of the
monarchy has been diminished.
This painting is from 1656.
Remember, it's later than
the Quixote,
but history didn't move that
fast in the period,
so 1605 first Quixote,
1656,
fifty years give or take,
but by the seventeenth century
the Spanish monarchy has been
weakened.
It is in the hands of
validos,
noblemen who occupied positions
of power,
and the Hapsburgs were very
disinterested in governance and
more in luxury,
and all of that.
Velázquez painted the
Hapsburgs in some of those
activities,
hunting, and stuff like that,
but here,
in this painting he has
eliminated them from the
position of power,
he has placed himself at the
center,
and he has allowed us commoners
to occupy that position.
So this is the significance.
Now, the most important
parallel to this will come in
Part II of the Quixote,
but I will anticipate it here,
when Sancho Panza is made
governor of a mock island,
and Sancho, by the way,
performs well as a ruler.
So he, the commoner,
has come to occupy the position
of ruler, and this is something
similar to what is happening
here in Las Meninas.
So this is why this painting is
so important in relation to
the Quixote.
But I also want you too,
in anticipation,
look at this figure,
here.
The kings of Spain,
like many others,
including Aztec emperors,
kept freaks in their court for
entertainment and for amusement
midgets,
people deformed,
and all of that.
Of course, this is,
from our perspective,
horrendous, but it was
practiced all over,
and Velázquez was
fascinated by people who had
peculiar features,
irregular features.
He painted midgets and so
forth, and this is obviously a
deformed woman.
I think that she is important
because Cervantes too was very
much interested in depicting
strange individuals,
individuals who are not
beautiful, but who have been
scarred by time and by life,
and by bad luck, and so forth.
So when you get to the chapter
in the inn,
and you read the descriptions
of Maritornes,
the wenchy prostitute who
creates that whole fracas at
night in the inn think of the
face of this figure here flat
faced,
deformed, and so forth,
because it's another
correspondence,
a very important
between Velázquez's
aesthetics and Cervantes's
aesthetics.
So much for now for Las
Meninas.
We will go back to
Velázquez later,
quite soon, as a matter of
fact, to look at another one of
his masterpieces,
but for now,
so much for Las Meninas,
so we will go back to having
light,
both artificial and a little
bit of natural light.
The one thing that I failed to
mention is that,
as you notice,
in looking at the painting,
Velázquez has given
himself an important position
within the painting,
but it's not a central
position, he is in an oblique
position,
as it were, a lateral position.
This emphasizes his ambiguity
of the power of creation of the
modern author and at the same
time the self doubt,
the self doubt that the self
reflexivity expresses.
So it is, I think,
noteworthy that he is on the
side as it were,
and the creator is looking
obliquely at the model,
in the same way that Cervantes
says that he is father or
stepfather of his work.
Remember, what he said in the
1605 prologue that we talked
about in one of the first
classes,
the obliqueness of
Velázquez's position
within the painting is similar
to that obliqueness of whether
he's father or stepfather,
and so forth.
So we go back now to the
Quixote.
Now, after the episode with the
Biscainer, the Basque,
when Don Quixote injures this
man in this fight,
Sancho is very apprehensive.
He is sure that they're now
going to be pursued by the Holy
Brotherhood.
They, Don Quixote and Sancho,
move in a world of alienation,
of madness, of unsociability
and how can society deal with
Don Quixote's madness,
real society.
Now, this issue is highlighted
by the presence of civil law in
the book.
Sancho knows that they're being
pursued by the Santa Hermandad,
and who was the Santa Hermandad
or Holy Brotherhood?
This was a vigilante police
force that the Catholic kings
had created, Ferdinand and
Isabella, if you remember your
Elliott.
Why?
Remember they invested a lot of
effort in trying to unify the
Spanish peninsula,
but, as I've mentioned,
Spain is divided in several
regions with different cultures
and languages and exemptions
from the law,
where royal authority,
just like the federal law in
this country,
could not reach because of
those exemptions that these
regions had.
Therefore, the Catholic kings
created a police that could go
through those regional
boundaries and apprehend
fugitives.
The Holy Brotherhood was in
charge of the roads because the
roads were under the purview of
the crown,
and they were parallel to
another institution that the
Catholic kings created,
that also could police all of
the peninsula;
the Holy Inquisition.
The Inquisition could police
regions other than Castile;
that is Galicia,
the Basque countries,
and so forth,
and so could the Holy
Brotherhood.
The Holy Brotherhood were
feared because they could not
only apprehend you,
but try you and execute you on
the spot,
and Sancho says that he all
ready hears their arrows buzzing
in his ears.
Why?
Because Sancho is vulnerable to
the Holy Brotherhood,
whereas Don Quixote,
as an hidalgo,
feels that he's protected from
the law.
So Sancho is the one,
if you will notice,
who insists that they are being
pursued by the Holy Brotherhood,
and that they have to hide in
the hills,
and so forth.
The Holy Brotherhood--sorry to
give away the plot--will
eventually apprehend them but
let them go at the end of Part
I.
Now, the members of the Holy
Brotherhood were just ordinary
people who were engaged in this
police force.
So we move now to the adventure
with the goat herds and the
speech on the golden age,
that is one of the more famous
episodes of Part I.
Now, this is an episode like
others,
in which a contrast is
established between what Don
Quixote has in his head from
having read so many books and
the real world around him.
He thinks that these goatherds
are like shepherds of the
classical tradition,
and this is what makes him
think of the golden age when
there is now mine or thou,
there is no private property,
there is only goodness,
and man lives at one with
nature, and he delivers this
beautiful speech which is filled
with all kinds of clichés
from the classical tradition to
these goatherds,
who don't understand what he is
talking about at all.
What is the connecting thread
between that idealized reality,
that idealized world in Don
Quixote's head,
and the reality of these
goatherds who are listening to
the speech and not understanding
a thing that Don Quixote is
saying?
The one thing that connects the
two--and it goes back to one of
the points that I've made
before--is the goatherds'
kindness.
They are kind.
That is, that which has not
changed from those classical
idealized times and the present,
is the kindness of people.
And remember that I said that
Cervantes likes to depict people
from the lowest classes being
kind to each other and to Don
Quixote.
They have not reacted to Don
Quixote's appearance,
which is striking,
to say the least,
for this man to suddenly show
up dressed in armor and speaking
this way,
and they have allowed him to
sit with them,
to share their food and their
drink,
and to be involved in their
life;
so there is a sharp contrast,
but also a commonality here,
the people, the goatherds are
kind to Don Quixote and allow
him to be what he wants,
even if they did not understand
what it is that he is talking
about.
Now, this is the first of
several post-prandial speeches
in the Quixote.
This is another one of these
words that I'm going to teach
you in this class so that you
can be very pedantic Yalies in
the present and in the future,
post-prandial simply means an
after dinner speech.
So, what is the significance of
these post-prandial speeches and
what do they have to do with the
theme of Don Quixote's speech?
Well, after dinner speeches
celebrate the defeat of the
world,
that is, of animals and plants,
and end of work,
and there having been turned,
plants and animals,
into food.
Here they're eating some meet,
they're drinking some wine,
which is like the blood of the
earth,
they're passing the wine
around, and they are enjoying
the fruits of their labor at the
end of the day,
they're celebrating the end of
work and rest.
And there is a connection,
of course,
between the eating,
and the talking,
and the speech,
oral activities,
both pleasurable activities,
so this is the connection
between these post-prandial
speeches,
between the food and the
speaking, in others there will
be much more merriment and so
forth,
but this is a reoccurring theme
in the Quixote.
There is a great deal about
food in Don Quixote,
and in some cases food and
language actually coalesce,
most memorably when Don Quixote
and Sancho vomit on each other
after the episode of the sheep,
when they vomit on each other,
and it is as if food and
language have come one and they
have a dialogue between them:
I vomit on you,
and you vomit on me,
and that is a form of
dialogue--
I know it's not very palatable
to think about that,
especially if you just had
lunch--but this is the
significance here of speech and
food.
But the most significant part,
of course,
is the contrast between Don
Quixote's ideas and
clichés drawn from the
classical tradition and the real
every day life of these
goatherds,
who also serve as a transition
towards the Marcela and
Grisóstomo episode,
in which the whole theme of the
pastoral will be taken up at,
you could say,
a higher literary level.
The stakes are much higher in
the Grisóstomo and
Marcela episode because,
of course, the death has
occurred and there is a real
conflict.
So I think that the transition
here is smooth.
The transition is made smoother
by the figure of Vivaldo,
who--I'm sure you
remember--who's the man with
whom Don Quixote engages in
conversation about the nature of
knighthood,
and so forth,
and they all anticipate,
because they have been told by
the goatherds,
and so forth,
about this conflict involving
the death of Grisóstomo.
So we move to that episode in
which the main theme appears to
be that of free will.
The theme of free will is the
main theme,
but unattendant,
a very important theme is also
that,
again, of literature,
literature and its effects,
because Marcela and
Grisóstomo are figures
that are counterparts to Don
Quixote in their relationship to
literature,
because both Marcela and
Grisóstomo--
but mostly Marcela--want to
play act a literary role.
She wants to be a shepherdess
and take to the hills,
and of course,
Grisóstomo does the same
to pursue her,
but also Grisóstomo,
and in this he is also like Don
Quixote, is a reader;
not only a reader,
he's a student from the
University of Salamanca,
a former student,
a graduate, and a poet.
So the stakes here,
as I say, I repeat are much
higher, and it is almost as if
literature were on trial.
We can remember what the scene
is.
Grisóstomo has committed
suicide.
It is not said straight
forwardly because suicide is a
mortal sin,
and Cervantes is writing within
the context of very Catholic
Spain and he can't just write it
directly that Grisóstomo
committed suicide,
but the words used in the text,
'desesperado,' he became
desperate,
he was desperate,
all point out to the fact that
he committed suicide,
he committed suicide because
Marcela spurned him.
But what is amazing here is the
very detailed socioeconomic
context of the episode.
In this sense,
Cervantes is anticipating
Balzac,
the great nineteenth century
French novelist who gave very,
very specific details about the
economic situation of his
characters.
And here we have that,
because we learn that Marcela
is very rich;
she's the daughter of William
the Rich,
her mother died giving birth to
her,
and then William the Rich died
and left Marcela entrusted to an
uncle--
to a brother,
I guess, of his--who's a
priest,
and who will administer her
estate until she gets married.
Women could not hold property
out right, and the moment that
she married the estate would
pass over to her husband.
In the case of
Grisóstomo,
who is no longer a youth,
as we will meet later in the
book;
he's all ready thirty years old
when he dies because,
when Don Quixote leans over to
look at the cadaver he says,
"I saw a man of about
thirty."
Grisóstomo is also rich.
He has inherited a great deal
of property and lands and
animals and so forth,
and so it seems as if this were
a perfect match.
He is of noble lineage.
She's not, but this would not
be an impediment and it would
not bring down the line as it
were because nobility was passed
on in Castilian laws through the
male.
So Cervantes has created a
situation here for a perfect
marriage in a small village,
these two rich young people
would marry and create a larger
even estate.
It could become a
mayorazgo--a word that
you will learn about a little
more later--an entailed state.
Now, what intervenes?
What intervenes is Marcela's
desire to become a shepherd,
to spurn all of her many
suitors, and Grisóstomo's
mad pursuit of her.
Grisóstomo is a poet.
We learn that because his poem
is read at the funeral,
a typical Petrarchan
canzone.
He is also the one who writes
the autos sacramentales,
the allegorical plays on Corpus
Christi day,
so he did a religious play that
relates about the Eucharist.
He's a cosmographer,
he can tell what the weather is
going to be or the future and
all of that.
He's a kind of a budding
Faust--Goethe Faust,
in the nineteenth century--in
that he wants to foretell the
future.
He's madly in love,
he's a poet,
he has all of these qualities,
all of these sort-of-demonic
qualities that lead him to
desperation and to suicide.
In fact, he wants to be so much
in control that he has prepared
his burial in such a way that it
is almost like a play.
He wants to be buried where he
met Marcela, not in consecrated
ground, all of this raises the
eyebrows of the church in the
town, the narrator says.
His whole burial and funeral is
going to be like an auto
sacramental,
like one of these plays that he
wrote,
and his body would be the main
prop and the protagonist.
So we see other characteristics
of these characters.
Meanwhile, Marcela appears at
the funeral and delivers a very
spirited defense of herself,
using very precise forensic
rhetoric,
that is legal rhetoric and
legal terms to defend herself,
and the issue becomes who is
right at the end.
The women characters in
Cervantes are very active and
want to take their own destiny
in their own hands,
and Marcela is an example.
So one could say Marcela is
right, and this is what Don
Quixote determines,
Don Quixote acts as a judge and
he says: Wait,
because when she leaves and
runs into the hills people want
to pursue her,
he says, no,
no, no, no; he says:
I will defend her right to be
free.,
she has proven beyond any doubt
that she had no culpability
whatsoever in the fate of
Grisóstomo,
and so she should be free.
So, is she right?
Is she right,
or has Marcela also acted with
a somewhat selfishness by
wanting to become a literary
shepherdess?
To go around in the woods and
playing at being a shepherdess,
not marrying,
these two have squandered--
their estates--have squandered
this possibility...
Well, it is not as clear as it
would seem.
The question,
I think, remains open.
Grisóstomo has died,
he has killed himself.
Marcela has sort of suffered a
civil death,
a civil death in the sense that
she has run into the woods,
into the hills,
into the thickest parts of the
hills,
the text says,
and we don't know what's going
to become of her there separated
from society,
playing this literary role.
And so, I think,
the end of the episode leaves
us with a sense of ambiguity,
we have to decide,
as we did in the Andres
episode,
before but it's not clear as it
seems.
It also seems that the episode
is inviting us to consider the
effects of literature.
That is, literature has given
Marcela,
and also in a sense
Grisóstomo,
the idea that absolute freedom
is possible,
that you can live your dreams,
that you can live out your
desires,
and obviously this is a
dangerous proposition which can
lead to the kind of conflict
that we have here.
Remember, the one passing
judgment at the end is a madman.
Don Quixote has passed judgment
because, in a way,
he is like Marcela and he
defends Marcela's right to be
insane like him and to act out.
Now, this whole episode,
in a way,
concludes on a very hilarious
note which is the next episode,
the next episode in which
they're going to the woods,
where Marcela has escaped,
and they find a locus
amoenus,
which is a common place in
literary art and literature,
a very pleasant place that is
with grass,
with shade, with water,
a running brook making a
pleasant sound,
and so forth.
And what do we have,
what happens here?
We have here the translation
sort of this amorous episode
into animal love,
when poor Rocinante,
who doesn't seem to be strong
enough to harbor such desires,
meets some mares that are being
also put there to graze,
and have water by some men from
Yanguas--
these are Galicians.
We've met now people from
various regions in Spain--and
what happens?
When poor Rocinante approaches
the mares,
as the text says,
to communicate his desires to
them,
they meet him with hoofs,
they kick him,
and then their keepers come and
beat the daylights out of poor
Rocinante,
and Don Quixote and Sancho try
to intervene,
and they are also beaten up by
these people.
This is the conclusion in a way
of the Grisóstomo and
Marcela episode,
but in a humorous key.
Cervantes likes to work with
this contrast and with this
transposition of something that
was very serious and even somber
in the Grisóstomo and
Marcela episode into this
slapstick comedy episode of poor
Rocinante trying to seduce the
mares and being kicked
viciously.
So I think that this is the end
of the Marcela and
Grisóstomo episode.
The last comment on it as it
were.
Now, the knight and his squire
themselves are about to enter
into the thick of the novel,
which will be a counterpoint
between the Sierra Morena--
that is, these hills into which
they go--
fleeing from the Holy
Brotherhood, and also because
Don Quixote wants to do penance
for Dulcinea,
a wilderness like the one in
which Marcela was lost,
a counterpoint between that and
Juan Palomeque's inn,
the inn where the fracas
happened before with Maritornes,
and so forth,
which will become a temple,
a courthouse,
and where the complicated love
stories in Part I,
and you will see how many
complicated love stories ensue
will be resolved in that inn,
and so that is what we are
going to move into in the next
classes.